I also want to also want to you know you
and I planted a seed David we all you
know when we meet each other we plant
little seeds mmm and these are see it's
a friendship and in your life list
people listening right now you'll meet
new people and you may plant that seed
but guess what you gotta water that seed
cuz if then it doesn't grow the
friendship doesn't grow you do you do a
TED talk dude that's exactly and I owe
you and I pick up seeds planted all day
long but there's nothing sprouting it's
on the wrong soul it's on the wrong soul
a wrong foundation okay and that's on
you oh and the reason why it's on you is
because I'm your sensei I don't have to
reach out to you okay but you planted
this seed I feel like I'm growing you're
growing
I'm not girlfriend ship is not growing
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] I never looked at it that way
that makes so much that makes a lot of
sense so some tree yeah I'm a wisdom
tree right yeah but you know okay
I get it and you know what that's why
you're here that's right cuz you're
crafted with your words in your mind
thank you you're like you know in Fern
Gully when hexxus comes out when they
cut that tree down that's what happens
if somebody cuts your tree hexxus comes
out and kills the world what is the
hexxus no one's seen Fern Gully
it's a good anime it's like it's a
cartoon all right everyone in the room
right has a round of applause or now
raise your head if you've heard of Fern
Gully heard of it yes thank you John
holly is it yes there's bad
deforestation yes all right all right
well maybe you're wrong that I thought
it was about seacoast
name is hexxus that sounds so fun it's
about deforestation we're done with this
it's about divorce is that it's it's a
climate there's somebody big who does
the voice if it's if it's al Borland
bloom I'm not watching right now as the
best who Orlando Bloom Legolas
right in my mouth blue both shoot that
arrow right in my mouth Legolas okay
guess who the bat guess guess it was the
voice of the bat this is a this game
okay we're gonna do this only no we will
do this game but I'm gonna finish this
game but this game is gonna be we're
gonna go through it okay it's gonna take
50 minutes but let's just try it's all
right so who's the bat right so you
throw out a [ __ ] suggestion Steven
Hawkins its he is in the same Forest
Whitaker hey why no we would have
finished this game to its end
oh go ahead guys oh that fool that play
Superman was his name the guy from
crystal believed oh the one wood that
got [ __ ] up from the horse yes
why are you doing people there purse
please and then she said wheelchair no I
didn't say wheelchairs is it dead
oh no they are dead oh [ __ ] there here
we go I can't think I caught in comedy
Stephen arose defer Eve's he was
hilarious Gene Wilder Christopher had a
younger younger [ __ ]
Oh Oh bleep ass pleasure beep comedian
throws a little [ __ ] from passions is
it bill huh he died he died by the way
really
I remember passion you do wasn't that
show um hold on Travis no no was it yeah
and his wife yes
Travis Schultz was the start of it right
and then and then keep asking so Travis
Schultz is on my show splitting up
together Yuki's guest stars yeah I go
what's that [ __ ] like he's don't call
a [ __ ] so got his name but the
politically correct term is what little
person person anyways back come on guys
your your soap your kind of clothes so
not Christopher my chronic male comedian
white funny funny white person okay
iconic white I know I know it is Mitch
Hedberg more iconic then Mitch I know
Garry Shandling
um right in the same line as that think
oh this is we're getting Gary I'm not
getting close though
Gary Shandling um Robin Williams yes
you guys are no [ __ ] ferngully did I
win you did win that competition I think
you did huh
[Music]